le quotidien de ces éleveurs de rennes
ces nomades de la toundra est une
réalité parallèle qui n'a rien à voir
avec celle des mégapoles les hommes
s'occupent des troupeaux les femmes
s'occupent des travaux ménagers
on n'écrit jamais femme au foyer sur son
cv
ce n'est pas considéré comme un métier
cela ne permet pas de toucher un salaire
ou une pension
cependant dans les vastes étendues de la
russie il existe un endroit où les
femmes au foyer ont un statut officiel
il s'agit du grand nord
mais ici en vidant dit shum une tante
couverte de peaux de rennes qu'il faut
démonter déplacer et remonter plusieurs
fois par semaine
[Musique]
je m'appelle pavla le coma j'ai 48 ans
sinon j'ai commencé à m'occuper du
tchoum à l'âge de 17 ans je m'aime 31
ans plus tard je ne regrette rien oui
nous les donne aussi au petit de nuit
les flèches quatre mois mon mari et moi
sommes ensemble depuis 30 ans et il y à
19 ans nous avons construit notre propre
tchoum elle nous restons toujours cette
joie d'avoir notre propre maison
comme si nous avions acheté un bel
appartement la femme qui s'occupe du
tchoum doit être capable de tout faire
une femme qui exerce ce métier ne peut
pas être délicate elle doit être agile
robuste et flirte le confort et la
chaleur c'est nous qui les crimes
[Musique]
tu veux d'abord il faut savoir faire
rapidement la vaisselle des sortir des
fois chercher de la neige pour qu'ils
aient suffisamment de provisions
adéquates et cuisiner nettoyer faire la
lessive
il y a des petits comme lui il faut s'en
occuper aussi alors que les hommes
s'occupent du troupeau vas-y avec la
corde
les femmes font de leur mieux pour
rendre leur maison de 8 mètres carrés
aussi confortable que possible au milieu
d'un désert de neige le tube se
transporte facilement en cuisine on met
une table et si on pose les plats on
mange ça devient une salle à manger
si on a besoin de se laver gens lèvent
tous ces matelas et bâches jabès le
rideau jeu de danse au dos et le chou
devait un banc public
s'il faut faire la lessive au mais la
machine à laver ici là on la rue cyr et
c'est une salle de jeux pour enfants
le soir je baisse les rideaux de lit je
fais les lis ça devient une chambre
moustiques
si roanne où cela se passe dans le même
espace nous faisons tous ici il n'y a
pas d'autres endroits
nonchalant notre travail et notre vie il
n'y a pas de jour de congé
si je prends un samedi de congé je ne
mets pas le poil en rouge elles qui va
nous procurer de l'eau chaque journée
est une journée travaillée kate vient là
mon petit vient y apprend on l'a trouvé
à l'automne ce pauvre petit faon soit
elle a perdu son troupeau soit il a été
battu mais il est resté il vit avec lui
depuis quatre ans maintenant il connaît
ma voix il vient à moi il est toujours à
mes côtés
le matin quand je me réveille je me lève
il m'attend il arrive tout de suite et
commence à grogner à galoper autour du
tout - à condition qu'elle fidèle petit
renne je ne sais pas c'est peut-être une
sorte de récompense pour l'amour que je
lui donne j'aime beaucoup mon bébé elle
est si gentil si affectueux
certains ne travaillent que pour
l'argent ils sont malheureux lorsque
vous ne travaillez pas pour l'argent
mais pour des animaux comme ceux ci
c'est plus intéressant
vous avez toujours envie de travailler
nous allons officiellement prendre notre
retraite anticipée mais il n'y a pas
grand chose à faire en ville
les années passant cela devient de plus
en plus compliqué de travailler dans la
toundra et pas bhl à l'aide kova
envisagent vraiment de prendre une
retraite bien méritée et de s'installer
en ville mais la toundra ne la laisse
pas partir je ne peux pas le laisser
je ne peux pas l'amener en ville avec
moi même quand j'amène mes enfants en
ville pour une courte période cela me
fait de la peine de l'équipe et maman il
tourné partout il de chercher
[Musique]
l'élevage de rennes est une affaire
familiale
l'une des filles aînées de pavle à air
quelque part au delà de l'horizon
maintenant elle a sa propre famille son
propre tchoum et son propre troupeau
une autre fille lisa a décidé de rester
avec sa mère lisa n'a pas fini ses
études elle voulait vraiment vivre dans
la toundra et les revenus chez nous on a
vraiment dû manquer aux enfants ils
étaient impatients de nous rejoindre
j'allais au lit et je pleurais à chaque
fois je m'ennuyais jouvray le placard où
étaient suspendus les vêtements de ma
mère et de mon père je les sentais et je
pleurais ils m'ont vraiment manqué j'ai
dû tellement agacé ma mère avec mes
lettres et mes larmes qu'elle m'a fait
rentrer je n'avais jamais remarqué à
quel point la vie était difficile ici on
est trempés
pas grave on marche dans une tempête de
neige en larmes ça fait mal au visage et
aux yeux
pas grave on porte de lourds objets on
va chercher de l'eau on cuisine tout ça
n'est pas grave mais quand je me suis
marié et quand j'ai eu un enfant
j'ai compris que c'était très très
difficile faire bouger ça y est ils
s'écartent y en a un qui s'écartent et
tout le toit pour le suis insupportable
ces bêtes vasser apprend la corde et
oies et canards
oui c'est vrai ils sont encore jeunes
pas éduqués ils ont peur de s'approcher
les gens il fut un temps je voulais
rester en ville je voulais devenir
coiffeuse ou comédienne j'ai trouvé un
travail au marché j'ai travaillé comme
vendeuse cependant probablement
un mois et demi j'avais l'impression
d'être dans une cage comme dans une
prison
j'ai besoin de la nature je veux le
soleil et la terre
je veux voir tout cela je ne peux pas
m'asseoir dans un endroit clos j'ai
besoin de liberté et ce sont encore en
fuite
parfois nous passons des heures à les
faire rentrer les petits son alchimie
une fillette de 9 ans s'occupe de son
neveu de m
on a peur que les enfants se brûle il y
a un poil lieu schappler et je ne sais
pas si fine elle va pouvoir s'en occuper
l'ira visa il a de la moutarde dans
l'oeil
[Musique]
mon bébé pleure dans son berceau
je ne peux pas l'ouvrir parce que le
vent souffle mais j'ai besoin de le
nourrir
c'est vraiment dur il y à des fortes
pluies et tout est trempé
quand c'est comme ça je me demande
pourquoi je suis resté pour coup je me
suis mariée ici nous avons rassemblé
tous les jeunes mais c'était dur ils
sont trop gâtés mada patil devons les
rassembler plus souvent il s'assagit
rond parce que nous avons un appartement
mais nous travaillons et vivons la
plupart du temps dans la toundra
je n'ai besoin de mon appartement que
pendant les vacances c'est seulement en
logements temporaires un lieu de
résidence pour l'administration
notre vraie vie se passe ici nos enfants
grandissent ici et il est très difficile
d'élever les enfants dans la toundra
mais les enfants c'est nécessaire nous
en avons eu 7
ça va nous avons réussi donc nos enfants
réussiront aussi
les éleveurs de rennes ne reste pas au
même endroit plus de deux ou trois jours
le troupeau aura mangé et piétiné toute
la mousse qu'il ya autour
il faut donc partir et ce malgré le
temps parce que les animaux ont besoin
de nourriture
la famille change de camp une centaine
de fois par an couvrant des distances
allant jusqu'à 1500 kilomètres quand il
fait mauvais quand il fait humide c'est
désagréable dehors bien sûr personne ne
veut être trempés jusqu'aux os mais il
faut malgré tout arriver un nouveau lieu
de campement monté le tchoum et allumer
le poêle et c'est seulement à ce moment
qu'on se réchauffe frites et ça on le
sait quand les températures chutent à
-40 moins 50 degrés ce serait purement
et simplement un mensonge de dire que
c'est facile tout cela est très dur
parfois tu pleures étudie quant est ce
que tout cela se termine
mais ce n'est pas grave nous avons
grandi ici nos enfants ont grandi ici et
nos petits enfants aussi donc ça va on
peut y vivre
il faut environ une heure pour monter un
tube dans la toundra et ce travail
réservés aux femmes
chaque membre de la famille c'est
exactement ce qu'il a à faire
même si sa tâche est tout simplement de
ne pas gêner ceux qui travaillent vous
êtes assis près du feu en train de boire
du thé ces difficultés s'oublier vous
vous dites
et tout réparé à nos vies au patient le
matin tu te lèves du cuisine c'est la
même routine
jour après jour nous arrivons au post
d'entraînement fils vient s'il te plaît
dit le fils aîné de pavla a été enrôlé
dans l'armée
d'accord en a quand il y a quelques mois
qu'ils ne se sont pas vu qu'il arrive
mais la séparation n'est pas facile les
parents ont quitté leurs troupeaux pour
quelques jours afin de rendre visite à
leur fils
[Musique]
pourquoi pleures tu tu m'as manqué ça va
aller ça va aller il n'arrêtait pas de
dire élevé dé rennes ce n'est pas pour
moi
moi je suis plutôt versé dans la
technologie je partirai j'ai dit au
moins prévient ton père jusqu'à bien sûr
nous étions tristes
j'ai dit à mon mari que kolia voulait
partir et travailler en ville
nous espérions qu'il resterait car c'est
notre fils et mon mari ne l'a pas trop
mal pris il a dit que c'était son choix
et que ce serait peut-être dur pour lui
quand nous serions à la retraite voilà
collias
[Musique]
c'est tellement triste quand je sors et
qu'il n'est pas là c'est sont reines
je suis très attaché à lui il me manque
je sais que tous les enfants sont
pareils mais il vous manque vraiment
quand ils sont loin je connais mes
enfants je sais combien ma famille leur
manque
ils n'ont jamais été loin de ma famille
malcoste d'appel je pensais que notre
famille avait toujours été forte soudée
à ce paradis puis ils ont
progressivement commencé à partir les
filles se sont mariés heureusement que
lisa est toujours avec moi c'est une
aubaine
le plus petit de nos enfants à cinq ans
nous ne sommes pas jeune mais nous avons
encore des jeunes enfants certains
peuvent se demander à quoi bon avoir des
enfants à 43 ans les gens de notre âge
ont des enfants adultes les petits
enfants une vie tranquille mais qu'un
petit enfant arrive vous serre dans ses
bras et vous dis maman c'est toi la
meilleure vous vous dites mais comment
peut-on penser les choses pareilles
pourquoi ne pas avoir d enfant à 43
voire à 50 ans tu seras sa jeunesse pas
si moche hein oui bien sûr que tu peux
bien sûr que cela me rend triste que nos
enfants
aujourd'hui elle est de plus en plus de
gadgets de choses en ligne ils peuvent
rester assis avec leur téléphone toute
la journée
s'ils n'ont plus de batterie ne savent
plus quoi faire ces enfants c'est
quelque chose de nouveau et son hobby
fier parce téléphone c'est très mauvais
je ne sais pas comment remédier à ça la
civilisation sans filtre lentement les
choses de change certains ont commencé à
utiliser des motoneiges plutôt que des
reines pour se déplacer c'est tragique
c'est notre vie la vie réelle les choses
devraient être comme elles sont
mais tout cela disparaît lentement
pourquoi il était opposé
[Musique]
elle est rapide la charrette balochards
il n'y a pratiquement pas de nouvelles
tout se passe normalement l'été est
terminé mon fils reviendra de l'armé
d'un trois mois cela me rend très
heureuse je n'aime pas les verts mais
j'attends avec impatience celui là car
cela signifie qu'il sera à la maison à
2,3 d'accord bien sûr il me manque que
voulez-vous vous essayez de ne pas y
penser de ne pas attendre que le temps
passe quand vous attendez quelque chose
le temps passe très lentement
j'aime si vous ne vous ennuyez pas si
vous avez des choses à faire il y a
quand même une certaine tristesse dans
l'âme
j'aime tout ce qui est technique depuis
l'enfance j'ai des idées pour changer
d'emploi je veux abandonné l'élevage de
rennes les rênes sont un travail
difficile mais je ne veux pas non plus
laissé mon père tout seul il est vieux
et fatigué je sais qu'il est fatigué
[Musique]
je travaille ici depuis 38 ans depuis
que j'ai 14 ans j'ai fait quatre classes
à l'école
si nous vous avions continué nos études
l'élevage de rennes n'existerait
peut-être même plus cette génération est
en train de disparaître bien sûr ces
deux dernières années c'est de plus en
plus fatigant pour moi de plus en plus
dur j'attends mon fils bien sûr il
reviendra et nous verrons votre fils at
il l'intention de rester il l'avait
maintenant je ne sais pas s'il n'a pas
changé d'avis ne va pas l'intérieur suit
la corde nom et son père et moi avons
décidé de ne pas interférer avec sa
décision cela dépend de lui
il s'il veut rester en ville on s y
opposera pas
[Musique]
il a abandonné l'école tôt pour venir
avec nous dans la toundra depuis
l'enfance il travaille dur je ne me sens
pas très bien
nous regrettons de l'avoir laissé
rentrer tôt de l'école il a commencé à
travailler à 13 en main dit il amusé là
bas le travail ne se coupe pas honneur
la base c'est jusqu'à ce que le travail
soit fait cela dépend des serres et
souvent nous devons nous déplacer la
nuit qui est plat vous nous le temps n'a
pas d'importance fondateur chaque année
les éleveurs emprunte le même itinéraire
dans la toundra
je suis nomade depuis 30 ans et je ne
vois pas plus loin de mon nez j'emprunte
toujours cette route et on je connais
chaque mode il est très rare que je
puisse me permettre d'aller au delà de
cette colline par exemple voir ce qui se
passe là bas je vois très peu d'endroits
car je travaille sans arrêt nous faisons
que des allers retours il arrive qu'on
aille voir quelque chose derrière la
butte par exemple pour aller voir des
boeufs d'attelage alors du fond du coeur
j'y vais je monte les rênes je vais voir
je vois bien des endroits mais je ne
suis jamais loin du tout
ni de l'équation j'aime vraiment marcher
dans la toundra
mais je n'ai pas le temps c'est beau la
nature est si belle je ne veux vraiment
pas aller en ville pour le moment il ya
beaucoup de monde là bas tu peux ne sont
pas nombreux ici mais nous nous
connaissons tous nous n'avons pas peur
pour nos enfants
l'unité de ce pays dit-il en ville
qu'ils ont le soir si les enfants
sortent
je m'inquiète vraiment il est très
difficile de s'habituer à cette société
[Musique]
un hélicoptère s'envole vers la toundra
à la fin du mois d'août
il met un certain temps à trouver le
tchoum avant de prendre à bord les
enfants et d emmener en ville pour le
début de la nouvelle année scolaire ils
ne reverront leurs parents qu'en hiver
les gardes à nous sommes dispersés dans
différents endroits
donc bien sûr il est plus facile de
venir chercher les enfants un
hélicoptère grand véhicule tout terrain
car en véhicule tout terrain il faudrait
trois jours pour les rassembler il ya de
la route jusqu'à vorkouta il fait froid
il faut passer la nuit quelque part et a
donc été décidé de les emmener en
hélicoptère c'est très pratique très
bien
cette fois il y a deux élèves de notre
brigade veronica et fine à mes garçons
vont seulement m'accompagner pour ce vol
les filles vont s'installer chez des
membres de la famille et ensuite ils
repartiront 10 ou bien sûr que la maison
ne manquera mon mari ma fille mon petit
fils on travaille tout ça reste ici je
ne sais pas pourquoi mais mon travail me
manque vraiment comme ce n'est peut-être
pas bien mais ça me manque vraiment le
town je suis déchiré
d'un côté il ya les enfants qui te
manque car tu ne sais rien de leur vie
comment ça va à l'école et puis il n'y a
pas moyen de les joindre ces coutumes et
le travail qui te manque aussi il est
finalement du site par nantes
c'est comme s'il fallait être à deux
endroits en même temps l'année prochaine
d'anne il ira à l'école et il faudra que
j'aille avec lui je vais quitter mon
travail et m'occuper de sa scolarité
ensuite c'est timofeï qui partira je
serai avec eux et je ne retrouverai le
choco pour l'été avec les aînés on a
déjà eu cette expérience
maintenant je dis aux filles qu'il vaut
mieux ne pas se souvenir parce que ça
fait mal quand le bien que les parties
elles étaient si triste
elle ne correspondait que par des
lettres et les filles passaient tout
leur temps à la maison c'était une
époque très triste je ne peux pas m'en
souvenir
elle disait maman on rêve que tu sois
avec nous j'ai toujours pensé que notre
famille était une sorte de chaîne
incassable nous ne devrions jamais être
loin les uns des autres
nous devrions toujours être ensemble
l'hélicoptère arrive demain
les filles passent leur dernière soirée
en famille camarades de classe
respective ton style de vie comment tu
passes tes vacances pas tous certains
pensent qu'ils sont plus cool et que
leur réponds tu je dis que nous avons
beaucoup plus chaud ici que au bord de
la mer je ne reste pas au bord de la mer
sont bougés j'ai des reines et eux ne se
déplace qu'en voiture
ils sont dans la voiture collé à la
vitre il voit toujours la même route et
c'est tout tu attends déjà ton retour
oui pourquoi parce que ce sera à nouveau
l'été kg est il fera chaud tu vois et il
y aura le zum à proximité du peuple elle
a également du mal à se séparer de sa
maîtresse
cette fois la séparation ne durera que
quelques jours mais dans un an ou deux
ils devront se quitter pour toujours
avec ma soeur je disais regarde ces
photos
ce sont les reines que j'ai élevé elle
me dit ce sont vos parasites moyer de
départ ainsi elle dit pavla tout le
monde travaille sauf que tu en f1 pour
la viande et tu as puissiez de l'autre
je comprends pas ça je ne pense pas que
ce soit un parasite
c'est un jouet vivant c'est mon animal
de compagnie j'aurais
[Musique]
nous sommes exactement à l'endroit d'où
de son parti l'autre jour l'hélicoptère
a atterri ici mon resnais venu à
renifler je lui ai parlé la veille
on dirait qu'il comprend je lui dis va
rejoindre le troupeau ne cherche pas
maman maman reviendra j'ai de la peine
pour lui et il est parti après quand
l'hélicoptère est arrivé j'ai vu qu'il
courait vers lucho mais j'étais déjà
parti et il est resté ma fille dit qu'il
courait partout qu'il me chercher et guy
grenier
il me manque comment les quitter c'est
un grand problème pour moi vous voyez
moi qu'il découpe la viande je vous
parle de mon amour pour un rennes
les gens ne comprennent pas ça bien mais
c'est comme un enfant il est déjà adulte
il semble qu'il est grand temps pour lui
de rejoindre le troupeau mais elle est
toujours avec moi
d'autres grandissent et vif au sein d'un
troupeau et ça va je les ai nourris j'en
ai pris soin aussi mais ils m'ont
complètement oubliée pas celui là celui
là est fidèle pepel rebelles allaient
mon petit ya pas de moustiques ici
va avec le propos ils mangent toujours
près de moi
pacha tu as appelé le directeur
m
mais bon
[Musique]
il
les pas de connexion bonjour sergei
c'est la brigade numéro 5
oui sergey on est à cobra tite et aux
médias comme la dernière fois et
[Musique]
la viande est déjà prête
d'accord après demain le matin ou
allô allô les lecteurs ne viendra pas
demain mais après demain il est en passe
pas
allez
auvergnat non son nom restera un jour de
plus
bon
veronica veronica elle et elle est plus
forte alors que farinas est encore très
émotive
c'est l'âge qui veut ça elle commence à
être triste elle se met à pleurer pour
rien bernicat elle est peut-être plus
modernes ou quelque chose comme ça mais
bon au moment du départ elle pleurera
aussi je n'y vais pas pour longtemps
mais je vais pleurer de toute façon je
sais pas c'est que nous sommes très
sentimental dans cette famille localiser
le tchoum n'est pas chose facile car il
n'y a pas de coordonnées exactes
samba c'est juste à côté menacer suffit
on sera en retard vous êtes passé à
proximité
on vous a vu huy revenait revenez sur
l'autoroute oui oui derrière encore
derrière
[Musique]
faut pas les parties encore parti
peut-être qu'ils mangent un appel à
peine voilé du port est belle
le via mon petit bien comment ça va la
belle vient ici vient maman part
vient-elle
bébel
[Musique]
quel jeu
10 on récolte ce qu'on sème
je pense que nous nous investissons dans
nos enfants nous leur donnons de l'amour
pour que cet amour nous reviennent quand
on sera vieux ils diront papa et maman
sont arrivés n'est pas par exemple bon
dieu encore ces vieux que dieu nous
épargne cela faisait beaucoup
je pense que si vous semez de l'amour
nous vous récolterez de l'avant
c'est à nouveau l'hiver collias a décidé
de ne pas reprendre le métier de ses
parents et va essayer de trouver sa
propre voie en ville
il n'est pas retourné dans la toundra
mais bel est toujours aux côtés de sa
maîtresse qu'il suit partout
mignano change
allen hughes seul les rênes ne change
pas ils sont toujours les mêmes beau
adorable gentil ce long chemin sera
toujours devant nous et nous ne
cesserons pas de le parcourir et d'aller
de l'avant
[Musique]
oh